So and another
one to see if this time's opponent
comes faster 2 31 g oh neverend I just
lost with black so let's see how
it looks with white
aha well then I'll play the somewhat
unusual move sequence with B3
so let's see how black
stands up  probably in the
Leningrad
style with
G6 maybe also E6 with E6
okay, the second runner also
vies so the white
structure zi first of all for quick
development
A5 A4 problem in the
position when he plays that that could be
annoying but you also want A4  maybe don't
do
A3, I'll
have A3 on A4 B4, of course it weakens the white squares,
but you still don't think
that's a good thing, so first
develop it looks like
he wants to come with Queen H5, no
he doesn't do Knight
E4  okay, yes, first of all, E3, that's
according to the program, it belongs in the
position anyway if he now moves queen H5,
I would have had knight E1,
so now I could take on E4
and move knight D2 then I
would probably be forced to D5,
yes, that actually looks like
one after one  good position opening
for me
I now also have
F3 good he may be fast with i
maybe I'd better play C4 first
to make E5 more difficult or to force him to C6 or
something
but well he plays oh god he
plays very actively sees of course with
that  The lack of development looks
a bit risky,
well, but it doesn't look like
it can be put back straight away.
Well, the knight on D2 does
n't have a chance to bite here, he urgently needs
the move
F3, well, but he's not well
developed, I would take C5  I would like to do it
but B2 hangs could C2 cover
CD CD bishop D4 bishop D4 ed knight C6
dam
C3 then rook A1
F3 yes I have to play a little
faster
as far as I thought dam
C3 E5 is now an interesting move with
the CD5 eQ4 I have d with  C4 okay
E5 CD knight D4 is possible maybe
he has a good knight but it's
still not well developed yes
the question now is the next Z D
moves if I get to F3 and then bad F3
I should be standing very well
but black black has to be
I think I'll do something relatively quickly here,
the 7 doesn't do anything well at first, okay,
then I'll go with F3,
now maybe E5, well, no,
it doesn't want to somehow, okay, well, let's take
Knight, then it comes into
play too, yes D H5 is good1  It's logical
to
stand on it and now I think he'll
park everything on F3. Knight E5, that's a good
move. Yes, I think it's
already taking the pace to the 7 and
swapping a few of the active pieces away,
especially since D5 is now also a problem as far
as I can  Not so good now I
could also take the knight E5
D5 bishop C6 still looks good
for white CD bishop then
taking E6 with the bishop would
of course
reduce the pressure significantly, but I could
take the rook on e5 and then
go back again he could  also then bishop
E8
play
h well have to play a bit faster
so
tur5 so that actually makes a
pleasant impression D5 you also have
pressure
so if I now I could now
hit the5 twice and bishop C4
but of course only takes
once I reinforce we the  Position
still a bit Rook F8 I have Queen
E3 maintains the status quo
could move A4 but well, well
you can't think about everything now
CD5 I'm threatening now
just like
that, of course I can't take because of
checkmate and he threatens to capture well mus
I
make D5 now have a pretty strict
passed pawn, of course I'm always
half mated down there, so I think my next move
should
be H4 unless he doesn't have a
good
square now then I could also move rook E7
directly rook E7
then he does it  Queen F6 beats B7 well
I would still like to move H4 and
give the king a little bit on H2 another square so okay I'll first
H4 rook E7 I also have
D6 the hanging bishop f1en the hanging D dip
so
okay but now tur7 something  he then draws
Queen F6 well I have to play
Queen
F6 faster so now I could exchange Queen E6 for the queen
better
endgame well he doesn't threaten anything yet
but yes I think that with the little
time I have it's a bit too delicate everything
here so
ed yes come on  a bit faster here,
of course, all in all, somehow
more of a draw suspicion, this
game so A4 was once again important that
he doesn't get any very fast passed pawns,
so let's run at it, after all,
we have the rook on the
sieve, yes there could still be quite good
chances of winning
Actually, the time still
worries me, yes, okay, I have to
take the king a little worse,
so rook A8 is
good, I'll go forward again,
we have the more active
king
Time on the clock the
position is a bit
uncomfortable okay well then I'll run
to the front
check okay the position is now
really total
BTE could play well on time as always
very fair check check check check check check
check just about secured
but really
So unfortunately everyone here plays for a while,
almost everyone plays in a sideways
position. Yes, I should have gotten
more out of it, but it was
n't that easy either, I think